[Musik]
in heimischen michael mondstein wie
vater verzweifelt über schwarze frau
[Musik]
er hat einen aggressiven krebs zwei
chemotherapien haben versagt
[Musik]
ja es ist ernst seine letzte hoffnung
eine gentherapie mit krebs killerzellen
zum beispiel von novartis kostenpunkt
370 tausend franken und carrier ist erst
der anfang
diesbezüglich waren glaubten einige
sterben
wie kommt es zu diesen preisen pharma
durch zahl verständlich der markt etwas
ist was gibt der markt haar ist sowohl
vom markt werden die krankenkassen die
rekordpreise bezahlen
das ist viel geld aber bei 70 30 frank
ist für uns ist das thema was kommt ein
paar machen
es ist einfach schwierig und mechanik
ganz so wie das in zukunft elite co
[Musik]
das produkt das man verein er sieht die
zwei männer tot sie doch da andere sieht
die zwei öffentlichkeit zur richtigkeit
michael mondstein hat eine seltene und
aggressive form von lymphdrüsenkrebs
auch sein schäfer moderiert von der
krankheit seine letzte hoffnung heißt
camera ja eine völlig neue therapie
zugelassen seit letztem herbst dem
patienten werden eigene immunzellen
entnommen
diese werden in die usa geschickt in ein
labor von novartis dort werden die
zellen gentechnisch verändert und zu
krebs killer zellen umprogrammiert
die killerzellen werden vermehrt
eingefroren und zurück in die schweiz
geschickt
der patient bekommt die killerzellen mit
einer einmaligen infusion für die
infusion setzt novartis den preis auf
370 tausend franken
[Musik]
ob die krankenkassen kämmerer vergüten
ist zunächst unklar
sie haben sich zusammengeschlossen um
gemeinsam einen rabatt zu verhandeln
dynamisch martina weiss und ich bin
wieder helsana verantwortlich für
vertragsverhandlungen mit der
pharmaindustrie im moment politik vor
dem reihe mit novartis verhandeln 370
tausend franken seien zu viel
man wisse nicht wie kämmerer langfristig
wirken
ob der krebs nicht wieder zurückkehren
ganz klar wie so eine brust stand und
oder aus dem iran jetzt noch flüchtig
pro wir jetzt dabei ist wieso da jetzt
genauso hoch muss sie machen das ganz
genau reformen in dem sinne jetzt der
priester und die gibt es nicht unter die
haut nicht zumindest nicht sehen und ich
danke mir versucht einfach mal möglichst
hoch mittwoch in paris vorstellig und
weil es ist doch immer noch mitten in
erster preis schafft man immer ein
präzedenzfall der glaubt man als problem
und wenn sie im fokus ist lösungen
diskutiert wird ob die krankenkassen nur
im erfolgsfall zahlen sollen was aber
heißt bei krebs erfolg eine lösung liegt
in weiter ferne
vorläufig entscheidet jede klasse für
sich michael mohn steins billigkassen
privater zekeriya zu bezahlen
der nutzen sei zu wenig klar heißt es
leichter die hand
die verwandtschaft will die therapie
selber finanzieren
das spital verlangt als sicherheit eine
halbe million kinder ist eine
gefährliche therapie nach der infusion
kommen einige patienten auf die
intensivstation
die liebe gabi sich bereits um ihre
musik als bezugsquelle also liebe die
mir ist ja auch der bezug ist kauft
einen tv show betragen
so bezogen und ich bin bis jetzt nicht
braucht und deshalb muss ich sage sehr
berührt wäre jetzt da im umkreis waren
die reden jetzt taten sich stützen ich
weiß nicht viel aber wenn der zeitlosen
nutzer dann wirklich dass das team nach
einer geht's wirklich wahnsinnig viel
und das haben wir das hat mich sehr
berührt wir haben sich alleine klar dass
das geld im schlimmsten fall einfach
weiter und im allerschlimmsten fall
genutzt hat und weg ist
anderthalb jahre nach der behandlung
bleibt der krebs bei 40 prozent der
patienten wie michael mondstein weg sagt
erwartet
ja natürlich aber im vergleich das
medikament turin in italien
erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit von 20 prozent
und das funktioniert eigentlich nur noch
gehofft dass es dann am schluss sei
möglichst schnell dort das
einfamilienhaus zur nicht einmal
schmerzen und darf nun als drogen
zudröhnt stück musik die die heute gegen
die musik
[Musik]
wegen des streits können rund ein
dutzend krebs patienten nicht behandelt
werden
kritiker könnten sehr geehrt
krankenkasse verantwortet dass der
kranke patienten sterben
im verhandlungspoker mit novartis will
ihnen ja das ist natürlich nicht so wenn
du nicht verantwortlich für uns alle
dass wir einfach noch keine sekunde hand
oder sie sind tolle situation
michael mohn steins familie hat die
halbe million zusammengebracht
er ist der erste schweizer lymph
krebspatient für tim meyer
unterdessen wurden ihm immunzellen
entnommen
heute werden sie versandt sie gehen per
flugzeug in die usa
dort sollen sie zu krebs killerzellen
gewandelt werden so genannte t zellen
ob das wohl gelingt michael mohn steins
krebs wächst für ihn zählt jeder tag die
zellen brauchen ja eine gewisse zeit bis
sie produziert werden optimalsten fall
sind das vier wochen das kann aber sein
dass das ein bisschen länger braucht
jetzt weil so viele produkte reinkommen
zell produkt reinkommen bezüglich geld
eigentlich die kantonalbank vor banken
und die wir dies würde ein weil
eigentlich ist ein sperrkonto date bei
mir alles viel zu viel zahlen
für den zweck wir stellen sicher dass
das nicht angerührt wird im augenblick
aber dann kann man weiter fahren dürften
mal den lymphknoten tasten
er wurde aufgrund von patientenstudien
zugelassen finanziert von novartis
[Musik]
experten kritisieren die wirkung von
keymile wurde an weniger als 100
patienten weltweit getestet
die nachbeobachtungszeit war kürzer als
zwei jahre und kämmerer wurde nicht mit
einer bestehenden therapie verglichen
darum kenne man die langfristige wirkung
nicht diese kritik gilt generell für
studien zu seltenen krankheiten
[Musik]
das ist ja überall so das ist ja
intuitiv wobei man sagen muss es gab
auch studien mit ktc die mussten
gestoppt werden weil es eben todesfälle
gab damit weil es zu viele
nebenwirkungen gab und wie gesagt man
darauf das ist schon ja wobei man sagen
muss wir reden hier auch von einem
patienten klientel in den fall dass
anders an der krankheit sterben wird das
jetzt nicht am mondschein das aber
ansonsten oftmals viele
begleiterkrankungen hat die welt ist
halt so ungeduldig geworden und unsere
patienten auch da sagt man nicht jetzt
braucht man mal fünf jahre
das ist das problem die studie mit den
todesfällen betrafen nicht novartis
novartis macht folgestudien zu
sicherheit und wirkung
als ich nur sagen zu den preisen ganz
allgemein jetzt nicht nur was bezogen
sondern pharmaindustrie die preise ich
finde die preise sind in vielen
bereichen und ich finde aber dass das
wahrscheinlich dinge sind die für uns
nicht durchschaubar sind für patienten
wie für uns ärzte aber offenbar erlaubt
das denen jemand so hohe preise zu
verlangen und da gibt es bestimmte
interessen die dahinter stecken nachdem
man sich mit den firmen gut stellen
möchte standort weil die natürlich auch
alle in indien oder in china produzieren
könnten
aber natürlich auch arbeitsplätze ja und
natürlich beispiel schweiz so viel
industrie und dinge hat die schweiz
jetzt nicht aber sie haben ein paar
wirklich wichtige weltweit wichtig die
pharmakonzerne
im novartis werke magischen stein
treffen wir den europa verantwortlichen
für den therapien emanuele aus toni er
will uns zeigen dass kim reihe ab
nächstem jahr auch in der schweiz
produziert wird in dieser halle wie
viele kämmerer infusionen können sie
hier herstellen
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ihr die
genaue zahl nennen
dies wird ein wichtiger standort über
zahlen spricht man hier nicht gerne
lieber werden die hohen
sicherheitsbestimmungen demonstriert
absitzen eingreifen
jetzt kann man arbeiten aber nie kreuzen
kennen schweizer patienten einen
preisabschlag erwarten wenn die
transportkosten in die usa wegfallen
nein sagt aus toni der produktionsort
spiele keine rolle für den preis
relevant sei der wert den eine
gentherapie habe der wert von gewonnene
lebenszeit ein paradigmenwechsel
früher hatte die pharmaindustrie ihre
preise mit hohen forschungskosten
gerechtfertigt die prämienzahler wissen
nicht ob 370 tausend franken
gerechtfertigt sind wenn sie die
herstellungs- und die forschungskosten
nicht kennen diese zahlen
veröffentlichen wir nicht warum sind sie
geheim sind geheim
wir fokussieren darauf was kinder ja den
patienten dem system und der
gesellschaft bringt wenn sie mit dem
wert argumentieren können wir mit
antibiotika vergleichen
sie hätten das leben eines kindes mit
lungenentzündung warum aber kosten sie
nur einige hundert franken und nicht
eine halbe million
ich bin nicht in der lage in die frage
für diese therapie zu beantworten was
sich erklären kann ist wo wir den wert
von tim meyer sehen
das prinzip von werth basierten preisen
sei falsch sagen krankenkassen weil ein
menschenleben letztlich unbezahlbar sei
die kassen schätzen dass die prämien
sich wegen der medikamentenkosten
innert zehn jahren um über zehn prozent
verteuern
[Musik]
befürchten sie nicht dass das
gesundheitssystem zusammenbricht wenn
sie so weitermachen
nein ich habe keine angst ich denke wir
finden lösung
wir sind offen für wir sind bereit
zusammen mit den kassen und kantonen
risiken einzugehen um die therapien
zugänglich zu machen sagt die
pharma-branche die prämienzahler tragen
das risiko mit das risiko für kim war
das im übrigen gar nicht bei novartis
erfunden wurde
[Musik]
die spur der krebs killerzellen führt an
die pennsylvania universität kein
einzelfall
über 60 prozent der neu zugelassenen
medikamente in den usa stammen nicht aus
pharma labors ich heiße kohlen und bin
immunologe mein team hat kämmerer jahr
2004 erfunden
heute bin ich 65 aber ich arbeite seit
1992 an diesem projekt coaching letztes
jahr von kaymer gesehen zu einem der
weltweit 100 einflussreichsten personen
geführt
zuerst testeten wir die zelltherapie bei
hiv-patienten weil sie viele immunzellen
verloren haben
zwei jahre später startet meine frauen
eierstockkrebs dann habe ich meine
forschung auf krebs verlagert damals
aber habe er keinen dollar von der
pharma erhalten diesmal die forschung
zuerst nur bei mäusen nicht aber bei
menschen wirkte ohne spendengelder
hätten wir diese therapien entwickeln
kann philanthropen und die regierung
haben uns unterstützt
ja es waren sicher 20 millionen die ich
zwischen 1999 und 2012 bekam 2012 begann
die zusammenarbeit mit novartis die
discount ist die phase wurde außer mit
steuergeld bezahlt ja die ganze
grundlagenforschung die zeigte dass das
konzept der krebs killerzellen
funktioniert wurde an universitäten
gemacht 2010 der durchbruch bei
krebspatienten um die welt aber ging die
geschichte der siebenjährigen emily
white hat das leukämiekranke mädchen
konnte dank tim breuer gerettet werden
auch sieben jahre nach der infusion ist
emily immer noch krebsfrei bei kindern
wirkt immer besser als bei erwachsenen
damals riefen uns 100 der investoren an
und glücklicherweise auch novartis die
die forschung vermarkten wollte die
erfindung sei das eine sagt novartis die
forschung aber auf den markt zu bringen
sei aufwendig und teuer
insider sagen novartis habe der uni für
das exklusive verkaufsrecht von kim ry
rund 225 millionen bezahlt und für jede
infusion bezahle novartis der uni rund
fünf prozent des verkaufspreises der
konzern kommentiert das nicht
die gesundheitsindustrie ist nicht
transparent
sie wurde nicht zum nutzen des patienten
geschaffen bei uns an der uni kosten die
krebs killerzellen und 55.000 dollar pro
patient das ist ohne gewinn
fast sieben mal günstiger also die uni
macht aber nur kleine studien mit kim
reyer für die marktzulassung musste
novartis weltweite studien finanzieren
und hat zentren für die herstellung der
therapie gebohrt
michael mondstein wartet immer noch auf
seine krebs killerzellen aus den usa
plötzlich eine nachricht von novartis
der konzern schenkt ihm das camera ja
ich weiss es wäre wahnsinn freute sich
willi schimm wahnsinns große schwarze
muster um gott aber wie sich die nächste
patientin erste patientin das weiß ines
der stadtplan sind ja natürlich
man habe den ersten beiden schweizer
patienten kamera geschenkt weil sich die
verhandlungen mit den krankenkassen in
die länge ziehen heißt es bei novartis
[Musik]
michael mohn stein familienvater er wird
den lauf gegen die zeit verlieren
novartis usa teilt mit man habe seine
krebs killerzellen zu wenig gut
vermehren können
um kinder herzustellen 19 tage später
stirbt er
[Musik]
ich heiße wollten
ich habe 30 jahre lang in der
pharmaindustrie gearbeitet zuletzt als
jetzt bin ich pensioniert und seit fünf
jahren leide ich an krebs dies sind die
medikamente die ich täglich nehmen diese
pillen sind die wichtigsten sie sind
gegen krebs hat muss ich eine kapsel
nehmen ein stück kostet 750 dollar und
interessanterweise werden sie für 1
dollar hergestellt was halten sie vom
preis von 370 tausend franken
es ist verrückt dieses produkt wurde auf
kosten der us-steuerzahler hergestellt
haben sie die pharmaindustrie für mit
anderen augen gesehen
die antwort ist ja
und zwar aus zwei gründen erstens war
ich nicht patient und zweitens war ich
teil des systems
meine familie hat davon profitiert ich
wusste es damals nicht besser ich hatte
die firmen sicht verinnerlicht wenn du
älter wirst weitet sich keine
perspektive
röttgen war ceo einer firma die 2002 von
novartis übernommen wurde
er sagt bei kämmerer habe novartis auch
von einem 50 prozentigen steuer rabatt
für die kosten ihrer studien profitiert
die usa belohnen damit forschung zu
seltenen krankheiten
wir steuerzahler haben einen teil der
entwicklung von kinder bezahlt als
gegenleistung kriegen wir von novartis
einen schlag ins gesicht
er hat ein preismodell filmreihe
erstellt es basiert auf den angaben von
novartis man habe über eine milliarde
dollar investiert bis zur zulassung auf
dem markt ich habe einen fairen preis
für kinder errechnet
in diesem jahr liegt er bei 200.000
dollar dies unter der bedingung dass
1700 patienten in den usa und in europa
behandelt werden
1700 von potenziell rund 14.000
patienten wenn mehr patienten behandelt
werden kann der preis gesenkt werden und
zwar auf rund die hälfte von 370 tausend
franken
der faire preis ist so berechnet dass
novartis den durchschnittlichen
betriebsgewinn von 20,7 prozent erreicht
einberechnet sind auch die
forschungskosten von durchschnittlich
17,3 prozent auch der
krankenkassenverband santésuisse fordert
200000 franken für tim raue
ich habe das modell angeschaut es ist
voll von im korrekten informationen dann
geben sie mir die richtigen zahlen
das kann ich nicht das sind nicht unsere
daten die kritik an der intransparenz
der firma wächst weltweit bei der
weltgesundheitsorganisation den
krankenkassen und in der bevölkerung die
die prämien bezahlt befürchten sie nicht
einen image-schaden schöner worte nein
ich sehe keinen image schaden für uns
das ganze system muss transparent sein
nicht nur eine partei unsere regierung
verlangt transparenz sie veröffentlicht
die medikamentenpreise
es ist doch genau umgekehrt das könnte
man breiter diskutieren
das ist etwas anderes
[Musik]
wenn er genug kraft habe trainiere er
mit seinen hunden sagt kurt benninger
aus bern auch der 71-jährige hat
lymphdrüsenkrebs
wegen des streits musste er drei monate
auf den entscheid seiner krankenkasse
warten für kinder aufzukommen
[Musik]
die 100 prozentig sicher weil das gut
kommt wird die us verkäufe aber wir
verkaufen uns nicht gut oder kakao aus
der welt ist muss sie quasi nichts ist
nicht machen will dass ich mit rund 110
km reihe patienten gibt es in der
schweiz pro jahr
krebskranke bei denen alle therapien
versagt haben
dazu gehört auch anton schlösser 64
lehrer im bündnerland
[Musik]
mitglieder heißt bosnisches namen schall
apa ich weiß nur dass ich im herbst aber
nicht sein junger mensch regierung wird
sage ich auch nicht sie sind die schuhe
besagt wie viel abos pony hand des
abstands der heiligen bester folge
na ja denken eben auch eine zu junge
keine klemmt am spital oder sonst fehlt
die nötige jetzt oscar wildes leben
einiger massaker der kann jetzt sehr
gewonnen es ist schön wieder bei mir
fast schon aber liegt der preis nicht
festgesetzt habe es ist sehr unschuldig
obwohl sich das einzige was
verschiedener gibt und das nicht einmal
beim arzt ist das schon überraschend
überraschend auch seine krankenkasse
bezahlt für kinder ja die
preisverhandlungen der kassen mit
novartis dauerten vier monate wie auf
einem basar sei es zu und her gegangen
einige kassen verließen den tisch die
anderen einigten sich mit novartis
[Musik]
insider sagen die kassen wollten 45
prozent rabatt für kinder gegen krebs zu
viel für novartis die vertragspartner
hätten sich auf rund 20 bis 30 prozent
rabatt geeinigt je nach erfolg von tim
meyer also etwa 250000 bis 300000
franken darüber sprechen aber will
niemand
denn die vereinbarung ist vertraulich
sie ist sogar so geheim dass
krankenkassen wie die concordia die
nicht teil des deals sind den rabatt
erst erfahren wenn sie den vertrag
unterschrieben haben
[Musik]
das will ich skandalös
es ist sehr schmal dass ich mich morgen
wo minister den vertrag abschließe und
minute munter pries keine und das ist
insbesondere absolut neuen schweizer
gesundheitswesen krise um
vertragsinhalte sind transparent vor
allen der innovativen spital plötzlich
mit voller kostentransparenz ist sehr
sehr wichtig im gesundheitswesen
schleefs völlig gegenüber deine
großunternehmen muss vogel friss oder
stirb sagt er
geheimrat oder den vollen preis von
370.000 ich denke nicht dass das
zutrifft
so gehen wir nicht mit unseren partner
nummer wir finden lösungen heißt das sie
werden einverstanden da nichts den
rabatt zu veröffentlichen
wir finden lösungen mit unseren partnern
und stellen sicher dass sie nachhaltig
sind sie beantworten meine frage nicht
ich erkläre ihm was wir glauben
tatsache ist dass die firma ihre rabatte
noch nie veröffentlicht hat
ok wechseln wir das thema nochmals zu
erzählen name muss kurt benninger
in den usa ist es normal es nicht
gelungen die killer zellen herzustellen
gleich wie bei michael nun stein warfen
jetzt gut und wird das letzte training
buch der beschnitt pharmaindustrie ist
dann zieht einen die zahlen über die
wiener trotz der machen erst ende
kämmerer zulassungsstudie konnte ein
drittel der patienten gar nicht
behandelt werden entweder ließen sich
die killerzellen nicht herstellen oder
die patienten wurden während der
wartezeit zu krank oder verstorben wie
michael mondstein good news derweil aus
den usa für anton schlösser
bei ihm hat es geklappt die krebs
killerzellen sind auf dem weg in die
schweiz dann bekommen sie diese
immunzellen zurück diese karte zahlen
die sind noch deutlich stärker als
normalerweise immunzellen sind und was
passiert wenn immunzellen in aktion sind
dann gibt es nebenwirkungen
das kann fieber geben dass keine
kreislaufprobleme geben
die andere sache über die wir sprechen
müssen sind neurologischen
nebenwirkungen
die sind ebenfalls sehr häufig in
studien zwischen je nach dem 10 bis 40
prozent der patienten die können ganz
unspezifisch sein das können dinge sein
wie sprechstörungen
konzentrationsstörungen ebenso ist das
so dass es natürlich sein dass kann dass
organe in der zeit etwas vorübergehend
auswahl mit ihm ihre das wurde in rund
20 prozent der patienten beobachtet dass
tatsächlich patienten an die dialyse
also blutwäsche mussten
krebs killerzellen können heilen und
töten sie sind die therapie der letzten
hoffnung für patienten die sonst sterben
[Musik]
dynamisch alfred risikokapital investor
büro in san francisco größte healthcare
konferenz alfred scheidecker er
investiert in kleine biotech firmen die
neue krebsmedikamente entwickeln
sein ziel die kleinen firmen an
pharmakonzerne verkaufen mit gewinn
es ist unglaublich mit der ökologie
focus pharmafirmen romanesco sap die
übernahme wenn ich heute zeitpunkt wenn
sie halt ihre devise mensch macht dann
das herzmedikament jetzt in unserem fall
gewesen
diese menschen zum mittelmeer neue
medikament muss mir ein menschenleerer
noch funktioniert
[Musik]
60 prozent der neuen medikamente werden
nicht von der firma entwickelt sondern
von kleinen biotech firmen für die
studien mit patienten brauchen sie viel
geld und dieses geld kommt von
investoren wie alfred becker und marcus
hose
das seien wissenschaftlich zu breit zu
viele schulformen gestrichen und wilder
mag nicht alles machen neu durch löcher
meistens fotos universität hat jemand
aber gebraucht haben und bin am leben
wir sind dann habe das bindeglied
zwischen unterhalb von mir ist cool
sitzen und brauchen natürlich verlassen
wenn wir mit prämien belohnt wenn wir
jetzt mit einer so großen exit an also
wenn wir eine firma verkaufen oder an
die börse und sich einen drauf denn wenn
das gute nicht verdammen was man
investiert haben oder vielleicht sogar
sieben fachs was auch immer dafür haben
wir ein sehr hohes ausfallrisiko will
nicht jedes krebsmedikament funktioniert
damals riesig dass die relevant
die sich seine firma investiere oft in
der frühen phase der forschung die
farmer aber zahle dann am meisten wenn
eine biotech firma davor stehe ein neues
medikament auf den markt zu bringen
novartis kauft die us firma wechsels für
fast neun milliarden dollar gekauft die
biotechfirma kite für fast zwölf
milliarden für die access therapie
verlangt novartis jetzt den rekordpreis
von 2,1 millionen dollar hat novartis
durch den vertrag mit der universität
biotech firmen und investoren aus lassen
und so milliarden sparen können
beim inselspital patienten kurz
benninger hat die herstellung von
kämmerer im zweiten anlauf geklappt
[Musik]
für die 170 franken
das ist eine diskussion ehrlich gesagt
möchte ich da jetzt mich nicht darauf
einlassen hier an kranken wird
ich hoffe sehr groß dass der flug anton
schlösser hat seine infusion vor zwei
tagen bekommen
wir hoffen natürlich und das ist schuld
wir haben natürlich hohe erwartungen
aber das wäre jetzt nichts jetzt muss
ich einmal trotzdem müller am apparat
eine kantons vertreterin neue probleme
mit gema ja weil die therapie als
spitalbehandlung gilt müssen die kantone
55 prozent der kosten übernehmen die
kosten gut sprachen nur unter vorbehalt
dessen gibt dass die dass der kanton
seinen teil erträgt und wenn sie das
umgedreht sagen also deshalb lasse ich
das parallel laufen weil jeder von ihnen
beiden sagt als er ist natürlich nur
macht wenn der andere zugestimmt hat
[Musik]
investment bankerin vor hongkong und
china macht die meisten studien zur
krebs killerzellen weltweit
marktbeobachter sagen wenn die therapie
dort zugelassen ist werde sie rund
70.000 dollar kosten
danny lee sagt die chinesische regierung
setzte die pharmakonzerne unter druck
sie mussten ihre medikamente verbilligen
um zugelassen zu werden und die pharma
spielte mit als gegenleistung können die
firmen viel größere mengen verkaufen
wenn die pharma die preise hoch hält
sind sie zu teuer für den chinesischen
gesundheitsmarkt dann verlieren wir alle
[Musik]
frage ist es extrem spielen die
fluggesellschaft nicht zahlen wenn man
sie aber pharmafirmen eine
verstaatlichung nicht unbedingt ich
meine 20 bis 25 prozent gewinnmarge
das hat ja so schnell wird das hat mir
einmal bankhauses wachstum sei notwendig
da kann man ja keine oberstufe ich sag
jetzt mal unter durchschnitt es
vernünftig macht ja immer nur geld und
da hat man sich vier aus
gesellschaftlich bewusst und
verantwortet seit ich glaube dass
pharmafirmen eine hohe verantwortung
tragen sie sehr viel kapital in
hochriskanten innovation investieren
insofern trage sie große verantwortung
für gesellschaft hob am schluss 25
prozent grüne oder zehn prozent profit
oder lappen pharma als existenzielle
berechtigung von burkhard
wirtschaftlicher firma ist dass sie
profit erwirtschaften aber so gar nicht
stellen
jetzt haben wir selten zum speed-dating
mitflieger firma wo war in der
hauptstadt mit äußerer retter und erich
thies keine verkaufe ihre pix und den
warburger land investieren big business
also vor der finanz- araber big business
für mediziner patienten zur gesundheit
matchmaking im 30 minuten takt in diesen
kabinen treffen sich investoren und
forscher sollen für überlebenswichtige
therapien die gleichen preis regeln
gelten wie für luxusgüter
anton schlossers frau dokumentiert seine
therapie mit dem handy sind sie traurig
in den ersten tagen fieber und
schüttelfrost nur leichte nebenwirkungen
der killerzellen und jetzt gehts die
idiotische
[Musik]
dasselbe bild am inselspital auch kurt
benninger bekommt fieber aber sonst geht
es ihm gut
[Musik]
so geht die party für das nützt das
werden
o
einmal markus erscheint
diese biotechfirma forscht in einem
bereich der boomt medikamente für
seltene krankheiten so genannte orphan
drugs auch kinder ist ein orphan drug
wir fokussieren auf seltene krankheiten
das gesetz bietet anreize dafür
wir kennen eine firma die nur acht
patienten testete und nur zwei dieser
patienten sprachen teilweise auf das
neue medikament an
dennoch wurde er sind schnellverfahren
zugelassen
kleinere patientengruppen kürzere
studiendauer steuer rabatte für orphan
drugs gebe es noch einen weiteren großen
vorteil sagt investor scheidecker
in den usa und der eu erhalten
jean-jacques ein exklusives
vermarktungsrecht bis zu zehn jahre lang
werden ähnliche produkte von
konkurrenten nicht zugelassen ist so
gemacht dass sich lohnt das werk zur
last gelegt dass man eine gewisse
exklusivität hat über mehrere jahre das
heißt ein konkurrent kann nicht einfach
so vermerkt rot sondern eine gewisse
exklusivität wenn es nicht anders gibt
hätte maschine frühere spielraum für die
ausgestaltung mit dem grund ist dass dir
mal nach gründen suchen besonders die
krebsmedikamente tür wurde das internet
so dass ich sage mal dass ich mit 1 in
den usa wurde das gesetz für seltene
krankheiten vor über 30 jahren
geschaffen
heute kritisiert der politiker der es
initiiert hatte einige pharmafirmen
würden das monopol ausnutzen um ihre
gewinne zu steigern
orphan drugs und marktexklusivität das
thema erreichte vor einigen jahren auch
die schweiz kolleginnen und kollegen
gemäss regiment lege ich zu beginn
dieser berta der breite zu diesem
geschäft meine interessenbindung offen
ich bin präsident von inter generika dem
schweizerischen verband der generika und
herstellung um die entwicklung von
arzneimitteln für seltene krankheiten zu
fördern sollen die pharmaunternehmen für
sogenannte orphan drugs während zehn
jahren die marktexklusivität erhalten
während dieser preis dürfte für die
gleiche therapeutische indikation kein
anderes arzneimittel zugelassen werden
es sei denn es werden nachweislich
sicher und wirksam
der punkt ist pharmafirmen sind keine
sozialen einrichtungen sie forschen nur
wenn sie gewinn erwarten
damit es überhaupt zu neuen medikamenten
für seltene krankheiten kommt braucht es
ein monopol
dieses wird durch die marktexklusivität
geschafft als sebastian frehner ins
parlament kam dabei einen zugangs bird
dem damaligen interessenvertreter von
novartis novartis und roche spendeten
den bürgerlichen parteien letztes jahr
fast 900000 franken
am ende der debatte müssen wir
feststellen dass nicht die patientinnen
und patienten durch diese revision des
heilmittelgesetzes gewonnen haben
sondern dass es im wesentlichen darum
ging welche taschen noch besser gefüllt
werden können wenn der ganzen
kommissions- beratung und auch heute in
ihrem saal hat mich das gefühl begleitet
das ich und mit mir vielleicht andere
auch noch nur einen bruchteil dessen
durchschauen was im hintergrund hier an
lobbyarbeit
und die interessensvertretung läuft und
das hätte konsequenzen hatte eine buch
von pascal trainings aber damals bitte
gewandt dass inlandschef sich das hat
uns aus dem wert haben wir dasselbe nach
seinem achten treffer aus einem sinnvoll
macht mit uns reden bei uns wie halte
ich dass man mit fahrer freundlich uns
wird eher verhalten bilder gesetzt
ich habe das chemische kunden in mini
parlamentarische zwei jahre dauerte die
debatte
der nationalrat stimmte zweimal für die
marktexklusivität der ständerat aber war
dagegen das monopol kann nicht durch
dafür eine abgeschwächte maßnahme die
orphan drugs schützt
[Musik]
einen monat nach der infusion mit
kämmerer anton schlecker wird umfassend
untersucht
hat immer funktioniert ist der krebs
verschwunden
ich sage immer erst noch mal die alten
bilder da war hier diese wollen um den
port rum und dann war eben die haupt
masse hier in der muskel los und dann
natürlich am unterschenkel hier ganz
viel
es kommt nachher wo man hier nur noch so
schlaue aktivität hat da tut sich schon
noch was hier in der muskel loge aber es
ist doch mit deutlich weniger
für mich ist das jetzt mir nicht besser
vorgestellt ich meine bei dieser tumor
masse die davor da war das absolut ganz
weg wäre ohne spuren der entzündungen
bekomme sagte er habe jetzt wieder
bewundern wir haben keine glaskugel das
können wir so das wissen wir so
natürlich nicht aber es ist ein guter
schlaf
das kann man nie ausschließen
man muss sagen dafür sind auch die
krayer daten oder die behandlungsdaten
mit ktz noch zu kurz unterdessen am
inselspital auch kurt berningers krebs
ist unmittelbar nach der behandlung
verschwunden
sein arzt will noch nicht bilanz ziehen
laut der na warte studie zeigt sich erst
nach rund einem jahr bei welchen
patienten deren krebs wegbleibt über die
hälfte sterben
und wie die krebs killerzellen sich im
körper langfristig entwickeln weiß
niemand
schöne neue medizin welt
rekord teure hoffnung aufs überleben
kinder jedenfalls ist nur der anfang
[Musik]